okay hello everybody it is
uh time it's for uh 4 40 here in the uk
it's uh 5 40 uh in oslo
certainly can't be in oslo today it's a
real shame i always look forward to ndc
oslo every year and i've been going for
many years
my name is martin beebe i'm a principal
developer advocate at aws
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about building a real-time
service application in blazer using
aws um if you want to contact me i'm at
the biebs on twitter
you can see me uh quarter of the way
down that screen there at the biebs
and if you've got any questions or
anything which come to mind
after this or if you're watching the
video replay of this then please
just um tweet me at that address and
give me any questions that you have and
i'll get um
i'll get back to you also if you have
any uh requirements for
you know a free trial of aws or you want
some credits for aws
um i can give you a 50 trial for aws
just
uh tweet me or dm me at the beebs and i
will set you up with that
so without any further ado let's talk a
little bit about building real-time
service applications
in blazer using aws
so we're going to be showing you uh what
i'm talking about
in terms of what a real application
real-time application is
um because there's lots of different
definitions for it so i just want to
level set
what i'm talking about um i'm going to
show you how you could build those sorts
of things with signalr
and then i'm going to be showing you how
you could build those sorts of things
using
serverless technology and in particular
we'll be using the lambda service from
aws
using c-sharp and then finally i'm going
to
show you how you sort of combine them
all to build a serverless and blazer
application
and one of the advantages of doing that
and the whole reason for doing that is
is basically the costs involved so to
build the uh the signal our application
and to
have it working at a certain scale is
going to cost me uh
probably hundreds of pounds uh a month
hundreds of euros a month to run
whereas the serverless application will
only cost me well it cost me very very
little but
more importantly i actually only pay for
the times that's being invoked and being
used so if someone actually makes a
request in my on my
application and i'm actually paying per
request rather than paying
um paying sort of the infrastructure
which is just sitting there so
there's the reason i'm moving this to a
serverless rather than just being a
standard
uh real-time application is is to try
and save money fundamentally
um so when i talk about real-time
applications there's lots of different
types of applications that that are
real-time and
um the the common example would be
something like um a chat application so
something like whatsapp
when you're texting uh and you're
sending a text message to somebody
um that message is obviously being
delivered in real time so that they're
able to converse and be able to chat
but also things that aren't so obvious
are also being done in real time as well
so things like notifications and
things like little read notifications
like the double tick in whatsapp which
shows you that someone's read your
message
that's a real-time notification which is
happening some event is happening
in the real world and you're being
alerted to that event happening and
taking place
with the double tick and also when
someone's typing a message in whatsapp
there's a really irritating uh sort of
signal sent to the other user to say
that person's typing so you they can be
expecting that sort of stuff so
you'll see in lots of different styles
of application from
um you know a news website when a
breaking news story hits
um we're maybe sending that uh
we're pushing that data out to the users
in their browser so it pops up as a
little
pop-up now to do that we need some way
of pushing
data from the server to the actual
client user
and that's what a real-time application
is really it's an application that not
only can you can browse and you can look
at information but
it can receive events coming in from the
real world so
if a breaking news story breaks then
that can
alert your application and then the ui
can respond by popping up some
information that is a breaking news
story
um multiplayer games so if you've ever
used
massive multiplayer online games and
other characters their health their
position in the game
all of that stuff is being relayed to
you in real time probably using
some of the or similar real-time
technology like the ones we're going to
be showing you today
um document collaboration i
uh use things like quip or google docs
when you're editing a document and
someone else is participating with that
editing
they're doing that in real time and
they're using real-time web technologies
and um we'll we'll sort of take a look
at a couple of those so
here's an example on on booking.com
i haven't actually had to book a hotel
in an author a long time so this is uh
but
you know if you go to something like
booking.com and you're looking at a
particular hotel
you'll know that a certain point in your
journey they pop up a little message
like this and it says just booked in
london 52 product properties like this
uh
hilton in london and um there's a number
of ways they could implement this right
they could implement this on a timer so
uh you know after 15 seconds of browsing
a property they could just
put up this this this ui but what i'd
like to think is that they're doing this
in real time that um someone actually
physically really booked uh this
particular hotel and that they're
showing you that
in the in the ui now i don't know if
that's exactly what they are doing in
this scenario but
it's an example of a real-time
interaction and it's trying to drive the
the user to go and book this hotel
because they're getting this impression
that it's being booked all the time
maybe they're gonna not able to get a
room and so forth but something's
happened somewhere else and the server
sent an event
down to the browser to say that
someone's just booked
that particular property and then the ui
is responded accordingly
we use a document collaboration system
at aws called quip i think it's by
salesforce and it's a bit like google
docs i guess
um and one of the cool things that i
really like about this
application is that you can view um
who's viewing the document
and this is really useful if you send
out a if you send out a document
we have this thing in aws where we send
out the document and we read the
document during the meeting
it's a it's a peculiarity of the way
that amazon works so we'll all send a
document out at the start of the meeting
and then we read it for like 10 minutes
and then
we get on with the rest of the meeting
no everyone's on the same page and
everyone's definitely read the document
before we start discussing it
now one of the cool things is about the
viewing
thing is that you can actually see that
other people are connected to the
document and they're
viewing it they're reading it um so
you know that you know they've received
the link for the document you can see
that they're you know if there's six
people in the meeting you can see that
six people are viewing the document
they've all
managed to get access to the document
that sort of thing um
also it has things like there's a chat
functionality in quit
and it even has that really annoying ui
about typing where you know someone
as they're typing it shows you oh ron
swanson's typing
and you can sort of uh yeah it's
indicated in real time they're doing
that
now if you think about what's happening
when that user is pressing keys on their
keyboard
in that particular message box that's
sending a signal to a server somewhere
then that server is then relaying it to
everybody which is viewing that document
but someone particular is is is typing
so these are this is an example of a
real-time event something happening in
the real world being relayed to multiple
people
in real time to give a better experience
for that user but this is a particularly
annoying ui because
what i always find is someone starts
typing and you go oh what are they
typing so you're waiting you're waiting
and then they delete the message and
then you oh god
right so it's it there's certain
anti-patterns perhaps to real-time
applications but
um it's it's a useful piece of user
interface
which is developing so the vast majority
of applications today are going to be
using websockets to achieve
this real-time application now that
that's whether they're a browser-based
application
or whether they are a mobile phone
application or even an iot application
they'll probably be using
something like web sockets or in fact
they'll be using web sockets
to um to communicate now websockets
is a it's a protocol which allows
us to send messages not only to a server
but receive them back from a server
and that's really something which http
isn't capable
of you can send a hdb message to a to a
server
and make a request and it gives you a
response but the server then
can't at a later stage send you
something else
you know it's a one-time thing and the
request always comes from the user
making a request of the page or the web
server the server can't ever make a
request back to the user
well websocket solves that problem by
basically creating or instantiating a
pipe
between the server and the application
by which communications can travel back
and forth
and the good thing about websockets is
once you've got the pipe set up
there's no serious overheads in terms of
the data which is being transmitted
so with a http request every time you
make a http request
um you know you have to send over the
cookies you have to send over the
headers
you have to you know there's lots of
stuff other than just the request which
goes through
but with a websocket connection um you
can just send literally the data once
it's
started and negotiated and set up
then data can freely transfer between
the app and the server or more
importantly from the server directly to
the app
now a websocket negotiation happens
something like this you make a http
request to the server
and um it's a specifically request um
crafted http request it's called
negotiation handshake
and it says basically to the server do
you support websockets
and the web server reply replies look
it's 2020.
of course i do that wasn't always the
case years ago um
you know there's absolutely servers and
application frameworks which did not
support
um websockets but in almost all
scenarios nowadays you'll find that
mostly the clients and mostly the
servers will basically support
websockets
and because they both both sides of this
equation support websockets
on both sides have to be able to support
web sockets to enable it
they will be able to create a new pipe
which they can communicate
between each other so
um when i got into uh real-time
applications or building real-time
applications it was sort of around
2008 2009 time and i was using a
framework
or i got into a framework called signalr
now signalr is an incredible
framework for building these sorts of
real-time applications and it means that
you don't really need very much
understanding of how websockets work um
you can program in c
sharp and uh and um
it's got a really nice sort of developer
abstraction over the top of it
and you know it makes it very simple to
write sort of applications it's an open
source
um framework um you can still use it
today you can use it in.net for
the full framework net or you can use it
in uh
net core as well um it's um
it is uh open source as i say and it
supports a number of different
transports so i've talked about web
sockets there are other transports that
i'm not going to go into
but there are other ways of doing
real-time communication and signalr is
really nice in that it
it wraps them all up for you and
basically chooses whichever is the best
option at the time depending on
what the server supports what the
application supports and various other
things
it's not it's not talking about signalr
but it's just an important thing
to sort of explain what i'm trying to
build here because
when i built my signalr application and
i moved to aws which is about a year and
a half ago
i decided to see how i could deploy a
similar application on aws
now the simplest service at aws i'd say
to publish a net application is a
service called
amazon elastic beanstalk and what that
does
is if you're on visual studio let's say
you can
build a dotnetapplication.net4
core and you build it and if you have
the aws
sdk installed you can right-click the
project
and you can say deploy to elastic bean
store
and what it will do is it will wrap up
your code build your code put it into a
zip file effectively
and in the background it posts that to
aws and then aws takes that code
and it puts it on some infrastructure
now the infrastructure
that you set up you can say i want one
server or i can
want 10 servers i want it to auto scale
between 1 and 10 servers
i want a load balancer in front of it
you make all those decisions when you're
doing the deployment
and then it will basically put the web
application on however many servers that
you want
so i took my signalr application i stick
it on
i build it using elastic beanstalk
because
it's easy i use the visual studio way of
doing it but you could easily you can
easily do it from command line as well
but i say okay publish it to beanstalk
and what it does it creates a load
balancer for me and it creates
um two instances so i've got two
instances
sorry two web servers in aws we call
those instances
two instances each running my
application and a load balancer which
load balances
between the two now um
the only thing that i had to change
really to get this working
was to say well the load balancer that
needs to be
sticky sessions and because the way
signalr works once the web
connection is set up a websocket
connection is set up you want the person
going back to the same web server
so i set up sticky sessions on the load
balancer and pretty much
my application works so just to show you
what that application looks like if we
go
if you have a mobile phone and you have
a camera
or if you just want to punch in the url
signalr.beeps.net
and uh but i'm going to just scan it
with my camera this qr code and it will
take me to the url
and i should then receive like a little
thing which says please wait
so it's like a little gray screen so
once a couple of you people
have uh have gone to that site then what
i will be able to do
is i should be able to go uh and click
through to the next thing
and what will happen is my phone will
have been updated
with um uh a question it says what drink
coffee or beer
and i see a few of you have already
started to vote and five of you saying
coffee
six saying beer i'm gonna vote for
coffee i don't drink
six and six so today at ndc we've got
like six seven oh
actually coffee's coffee's taking the
lead there's there's uh
there's people voting for uh coffee and
beer using the application
and you'll see that as you press the
button on the application it sends a
signal
that's received by the application it
updates the the counter on
one of the sites right now if i go over
to tabs versus spaces
interesting never mind um i don't know
quite what went wrong there
but you can vote versus tabs versus
spaces and we can see oh
before it crashed out i don't know why i
was doing that but
never mind um we're roughly generally
going to say that tabs tabs are winning
for some reason i'm going to take it off
that screen for some reason
because it's not quite working how i
expect it to uh luckily the the signalr
demo is not actually what i was going to
show today so that's uh
that's good um but uh
roughly what's happening there the the
idea is we've got our load balancer
we've got our two instances
and it's balancing between the two um
applications working as you connect to
it you're connecting to one of those two
instances
and all should be kind of well with that
but there is a slight problem um if uh
because we have two instances and we
have messages going back and forth and
websockets
when i vote the voting doesn't always
happen
on uh the message doesn't always get
sent to both machines
you see when i say i i'm voting or
incrementing a number to say i want to
vote for coffee
that that message only gets sent to the
server that i'm connected to it doesn't
get distributed to the other servers
and so this is a common problem in
real-time applications
if you've got a backup you've got a a
number of servers which are
in a in a application then they actually
need to talk to each other as well
to be able to pass the messages back and
forth so that you've got um
the correct messages going to so the
application's functioning correctly is a
sort of unit rather than as
individual applications uh separated now
the way that we solve this in something
like signalr and in many sort of
common uh scenarios is we use a thing
called a backplane
and a backplane is basically some kind
of mechanism which stands behind the
application
which we can communicate uh so the
servers can cross
communicate and pass the messages back
and forth so that everyone's got the
correct messages
um in the real-time applications and now
um to do that on aws
okay now i would have to go and set up a
backplane and signalr
the preferred back pain for signalr is
something called redis
we have a service at aws called amazon
elasticash for redis
which is basically a managed redis
service so i can stand up a
manage redis service and it's
set up as my backplane once i've
basically created that that thing
i go into my net core application and
all i have to do is actually add
this one line of code or a couple of
lines of code which says on my
our installation dot add stack exchange
redis and then i pass the connection
string to my redis
cluster and then i set up a channel
prefix which basically means
um the communications for this
particular
my application is going to communicate
on this particular channel called myapp
and then basically that's really all you
have to do to set up the backplane in
signalr singular takes a lot of the
complication out of something like this
and but there is a challenge with this
now okay i wanted to build a simple
real-time application and all of a
sudden
i've got a load balancer i've got two
machines
i've maybe got 10 machines um and then
i've got have a back back
a back plane which is a cluster of
machines running redis
and all of a sudden this is starting to
get quite expensive so to do a demo
like i did before where i had one or two
machines it's not very expensive to run
something like that but when you're
actually scaling this if you wanted to
build
facebook messenger uh on this
infrastructure
or some kind of chat application where
you're expecting hundreds or thousands
of people to be communicating at one
time
or you're building a real-time news
application which is doing
updates in the browser of real-time
events happening
then you're going to have to scale this
infrastructure pretty
pretty hard and it's going to be
expensive and it's going to be
complicated
so i was kind of wondering well is there
an
easier way and a few years ago aws
released a thing called the api gateway
api gateway web sockets and this is what
i'm going to be integrating today
into a blazer application so api gateway
and web sockets
is basically a api gateway is almost
like a thing which just stands up in the
cloud
and you can um send messages to it and
it will route
those messages to other systems
so um you can think of it as as like a
gateway
for your api i don't know why i said
that you can think of it as like
something you put in front of your
application to provide an api or unified
endpoint to your application um your
application doesn't have to
be one single application it could be
multiple applications but you're
unifying them through this api gateway
so that's what api gateway was commonly
used for but then they added this
support for web sockets
and what that means is that you can
basically um
not only can you manage you do use it as
like for an api
you can also deal with web sockets
communication
and what they're promising is basically
we'll manage all of the websocket
communication
stuff for you and you just implement
your application
as you would normally and we will
maintain all the connections for the
clients and we'll
we'll set up a system where you can post
to all of your connected clients
but it's much more straightforward than
having to deal with web sockets natively
so let's uh explain a little bit more
about what this means
so we have um application or things
like mobile applications chat
applications dashboards
iot devices web browsers which connect
to our api gateway
and so they connect to a websocket
endpoint and a websocket url
and then in the back end we have our
infrastructure now i'm going to be
building
using serverless infrastructure so i'm
going to be using lambda functions in
the background
but these could be containers they could
be an existing api
um whatever really um api gateway can
forward onto any kind of other system
but i'm going to set up a websocket
system and then i'm going to forward it
to some lambda functions
so what happens is the mobile
application is just going to use this
this standard websocket client that it
has in in its sdk
and it's going to connect to a websocket
endpoint that
um the amazon api gateway is going to
provide
so that's going to be like wss colon
slash so instead of https or http
it's going to say wwss which is
basically a websocket
secure a secure websocket you'll
sometimes see a ws
colon slash that's just a web socket but
a uh
a websocket colon slash a secure
websocket
then it's going to have a unique id
execute.api
then the region that this is running in
so if i was using using it in
in eu west1 it would say eu west1 there
dot amazon.com forward slash and then
the name of the stage that you're using
um you can create in the apis different
stages whether they be prod
dev or test or something like that um i
often will just use the stage name
prod because i like pushing everything
to production and uh
what happens is these um these devices
connect the api gateway and they just
set up a a websocket connection between
the two
but api gateway when it receives a
message
over the websocket it just invokes
whatever's on the back end
like a restful communication it doesn't
do over websockets it just invokes it
um it invokes it and it passes over to
the invocation a connection id
and the idea is that because you're
being invoked and you've got a
connection id
if you want to speak back to that
connection you have this id that you
could
call at a later date so you have this
duplex communication setup
but it's important to remember that the
lambda functions themselves have no idea
that they're involved in a real-time
application they are just
dumb lambda functions and they're
receiving an invocation
with a connection id and if they want to
they can respond to that connection id
what i actually do when when someone
connects to this system
they pass over their connection id i put
it into a database
um in this instance we're using dynamodb
and basically anyone which connects to
my websocket
i put their id into a database
and then we have a way of taking those
ids out of the database
and calling them and basically sending a
message to everyone
so we're able to send messages to
everyone which is currently connected to
our system
basically if i loop over the database
and all the connection ids
and i use this particular url with this
connection id crafted on it i can post
messages
to the individuals now i'm actually not
posting messages to the individual
people
what i'm doing is i'm posting a message
back to the amazon api gateway
and then that's then forwarding it on to
the correct connection
so from an endpoint user point of view
they've got this real-time communication
happening
but the reality is it's all the magic's
all happening in the api gateway it's
the one which is instead
is maintaining the connections it's the
one which is understanding or creating
connection ids and matching them back up
and passaging messages
messages back and forth
so we have um this thing called the
websocket url
and as a message is being sent to the
api gateway invokes
um the uh it invokes the lambda function
and we store some of that in dynamodb
let's say now we want to do the opposite
way we want the server to be able to
message the client
now i mentioned before um i can have a
lambda function which basically goes
into all of my dynamodb
database it gets a list of all of the
connection ids and then it
posts something to each of those
connections the way it posts
them is that just use a connection url
it's called a connection url
it's got a random number the region
number
and then here at the end a really
important bit which is the connection id
and if you do a post to that connection
id then you can send a message to it and
it will get rooted by
api gateway back to the person which
which invoked it right
now the connection url has a couple of
methods on it we can post to it which is
send a message to that particular user
we could do a get on it which basically
gives us the the status of that current
user
or we can delete it which removes that
user from our system
um or basically to disconnect that's
their their socket url um their
websocket
so if we wanted to create one of these
apis we go into
aws console and we create a
a websocket api we give the api a name
my fancy ndc api
we give it a thing called a root
selection expression
this is basically what the api gateway
is going to use to route the messages
coming in
to different lambda functions
and then once i have that
created
we go once i have that api created
you'll see that there's a couple of
routes already set up
so what we can do is we can say we're
going to connect this particular route
to a lambda function and we're going to
just i've got some lambda functions
already set up
one called onconnect
i'm going to set up the disconnect one
as well there's a lambda function which
happens or is called when any
anyone called disconnect to this service
and we're going to create a new route
called send message
and we're going to put that into the
lambda function called seven message so
i've got three
functions lambda functions and uh one
api
gateway deploy that api
give your stage a name you can have as
many stages as you like i'll call one
called prod
it's my production api
and deploy that and then you'll see
we have this websocket url and we have a
connection url so a url for that
particular connection
so the websocket url is what we would
use inside of our application
to instantiate or create a websocket
communication to our application
and the connection url is if we have a
connection id
or a number of connection id we can we
can basically post to those connection
ids and send messages
to the different people connected to our
service
so my application what it does is it
crafts
this particular um this sort of payload
and this is what the message it passes
through the
um the websocket and when i pass this
message you'll see that it's got this
this this one property called message
send message
now message is what it's actually going
to be rooted on so it's like the root
key
so if i pass this it's going to be my
api gateway is going to receive it
as a web socket request and it's going
to say okay
send message let me go and route that to
the send message
lambda function it doesn't have to be a
lambda function i could have routed it
to
an api endpoint which is backed by an
iis web server
i could you know it doesn't have to be a
lambda function but i'm going to post it
to allow this lambda function and that's
the connections that i've made and the
data that i'm going to pass over is just
saying hello ndc
now this this doesn't have to just be
such a simple package
it could be it could have multiple
things in here it doesn't even actually
need to be json but it's that helps with
the scenario we're doing
so i'm going to just say i want a
message with send message and if i
posted this
to that particular websocket url then
i would have posted a message um and it
would get rooted to my lambda function
called send function
this is the way that my sort of
architecture looks in this scenario
we have uh the amazon api gateway the
client application
now the client application can be really
done it can just be
a http uh html sorry page
uh you know a very straightforward
inexpensive um static
uh website and that's just gonna create
a
a websocket and then that will connect
it up to api gateway
and then as i send messages to it it's
going to route those messages to the
correct lambda functions
now when i instantiate a connection the
first thing that's going to happen
when i instantiate a a websocket
communication
by default the thing that gets passed is
on connect
so what happens is it will go to the on
connect lambda function
now my on connect lambda function what
it does is it takes the connection id
which is passed to it
and it stores it in dynamodb i also have
a lambda on disconnect function
and so whenever someone disconnects from
the websocket it will automatically send
a message to that
which basically says hey this is an id
which is no longer connected to the
service and what that
function does is it goes into the
database and it removes
that connection id the point being my
dynamodb should have a list of
connection ids at any given point
of everyone connected to my application
now i'm using dynamodb as a storage but
this could be
any kind of cache really
what send message is doing then as well
is once someone's
someone makes a message and crafts it in
that particular way so that uses the
send message functionality
it will go to the dynamodb it will
download all of the current connected
clients
it will send the message to each of
those connected clients
and so everyone receives the message
so this is um i won't go too much into
the code because
um i have it uh on github and i can
share it later it'll be easier probably
to look at there
but basically this is the uh send
massive message function
now the send message function what it's
doing and it's got some logging in and
so forth here
but we're taking this um property the
data property
which is the message and we're putting
it into a stream
and then we're asking for uh this is a
uh the way that we go and get all of the
items inside of dynamodb dynamodb by the
way is a nosql database
very performant quite well suited for
this kind of task
and it basically does a scan and says
give me back um
all of the all of the connection ids
and once i've got those connection ids
what i can do
is i can loop through them so for each
item in those connection ids
and for each of those what i'm
ultimately doing is i'm posting
the message to the connection so
i use this little helper function to
actually create the url for me and
create the um
the connection urls for me but
ultimately i'm basically looping through
if there's 500 people connected to my
service i'll look for those 500 people
and i'll send them all
a message via a post effectively
um so let's just show you what that
ends up looking like so
if i go to a website called
chat.thebeebs.net
you'll see it it's pre-pitted with
a url or it's already got a url in there
and i can connect to that url
it should be able to connect yeah and if
you go to chat.thieves.net as well you
can join in
uh with this fun too uh let me go and
set up another browser
connects up and if i type in hello there
that's odd oh yeah i've received a
message with hello which is what i sent
and someone else has sent a message for
it as well and then on the other side
you can see
so i can say window one
send message and over here window one
and i can say
window two over here
and someone said hey there as well so
people are connecting to this
application
uh and and it's basically a very very
straightforward and simple application
it's using
that connectivity back in the background
now uh
i think let me have if you go to my
github
um you have the biebs
sorry i can't remember the name of the
repository um is it this one
yeah so the actual code which is running
on the screen there is just a simple
html page
it's super straightforward it's built in
did i build this in view i can't
remember um
if i look at the javascript you'll see
that i have a
a a connect function a disconnect
function the same message function
and it's just basically crafting these
uh
send messages just crafting a thing
saying send message
and then passing some data across
onconnect is just setting up a websocket
connection
and yeah i'm using view there to kind of
update the scenario in the screen so
that's the code to kind of
enable that but it's all in javascript
and uh i'm talking about something else
today
we're talking about blazer so how would
you go ahead and
kind of do something in similar but
let's do it in in blazer
now in blazer we've got um two different
ways
of running web uh running blazer um
we've got a thing called blazer web
assembly
and we've got a thing called blazer
server
now i'm not going to be talking at all
about blazer server today
i'm going to be talking about blazer web
assembly and the reason is because
blazer web assembly is better suited for
what i'm trying to do here
what i want is to create basically a a
vue.js
style web application or a react style
web application
but i don't want to use javascript i
want to use as much uh
net as possible so i'm going to be using
laser web assembly and what allows me to
do
is create like uis um using web
technologies
but all of the logic isn't written in
javascript it's all written in dot net
and behind the scenes what blaze is
doing is it's using web assembly to run
your uh your c-sharp application um one
assembly is a
is a new feature of browsers and it's
it's
it's kind of this weird way of being
able to uh
execute things or run things which it
previously wasn't able to do and some
clever people have decided that
we could actually run other programming
languages inside browsers now
and blazer is basically beta webassembly
is that
it's it's a really clever little
framework
for building web applications
but using c sharp now this doesn't mean
that we're going to be using any kinds
of plugins this is not silverlight um
it's just using native web technologies
um it will only obviously work in
browsers that support webassembly
but nowadays that is almost every every
major browser
um but it wouldn't obviously work in if
you're still supporting ie9 this won't
work
um but the blazer servers are similar
thing
and basically you can take the same
application but this would work in
something which is a much older browser
but it requires the server to be doing a
lot of the processing and
actually uses web sockets in the
background to achieve the the
blaze blazer server hosting model
but we're not going to talk about blazer
server it's interesting but um
i've already i've already pretty much
run out of time for that so we're just
going to talk about blazer webassembly
and what i was kind of looking at is
well how do i port that first
application i built
into something like blazer now um i
haven't quite
got the style the same and it's just
purely technically how i would go about
and do it
and um this is a a road that i started
down about
uh nine months ago and i've gradually
kind of like revisit the application as
blazers matured
and added new features to it and and got
it to a point where
i think it kind of does everything that
the it does everything that this the
the vue.js application does it just
doesn't quite look as pretty that's
another job that i need to do
um so to start with blazer we just go to
um the blazer site
there's a little getting started
application
documentation if we click on that it's
going to tell you to
install.net three-point whatever it is
nowadays
and then um once you've done that with
the
net command line you can say dot net new
blazer wasm
um that's blazer web assembly
and then we give it an output like a
name for our project which is blazer
front end in this instance
and then i cd into that folder and then
you can just say dot net run and it will
build your application
and it's got a very sort of basic
application
where you can click a ticker and it will
update a number and increment a number
the cool thing is everything in that
browser all of the logic isn't done in
javascript it's all done in dot net
so in my application i've basically
tried to use that base
application as much as possible and i've
made a few modifications to it
so one i've added a uh a question
dot json with with sample data
so my questions at the moment are just
hard-coded into the application
obviously i won't do that in the real
application
and i've got like a question id 0 and a
question id one
and it's got tabs or spaces and coffee
and bm and so this is
roughly the data that i in my my real
application i actually store
in a database but i'm going to be just
storing it locally here
and i have a couple of pages that i've
added
i've got the index page a page called
questions
and a page called vote again it's
similar to my application
um i have like uh a voting screen
so if you went and voted a moment ago
using the application that was a voting
screen
that you said please wait and then you
choose one of the two options and so
forth that's the voting screen
and the questions screen is the screen
that i present to you
which shows you the qr code and then
shows you
as you move the slides or you move the
questions
and so those are the two kind of like
screens in our system
effectively so i've added those as razor
pages
now the first thing i do in the
questions.razer view
is we have this event which says
protected override async task on
initialized async so there's this kind
of
um workflow in a
a life cycle i suppose in a
blazer application and the first thing
when someone navigates to
the questions page it's going to invoke
this
um uninitialized async task now
i have just very lazily placed the first
thing that it does
is it loads whatever was in my
questions.json
locally that's a local local file but it
could obviously just pull this from
you know a database or another api
and it loads into an object called
questions now questions is basically
a list of my this type
of questions so i end up with a list of
questions
now if you've ever used single page
applications before you'll know
that the whole point of them really is
that you can create a state
so i can have an application state and
my ui automatically updates and reflects
that so i don't actually have to bind
manually bind my objects to my state
so now i've got a list of questions i
can basically create a ui
which loops through those questions so
here in my razer view
is the view which which displays those
questions
so i've got a uh if the questions are
null so there's nothing in the questions
then show a screen which just says
loading
else print a table and the table's got
title
answer one answer two enter one count
enter two count
now in the real application i use um
some fancy graph more fancy graphics to
display the images
to have that little graph in the middle
but for this purposes of this i'm just
going to just print it out to a table so
you can see what's going on
and so at the top there we've got the
sort of the
uh the questions the thing that i'm
injecting there
you'll see at the top is the http client
this is how we do dependency injection
in blazer
um we can also import nuget packages if
we want
nuget packages in the top there we could
if we wanted to use uh
newtonsoft json or something like that
then you can just import that like you
would in a c-sharp file it's got a
little slightly
different syntax but it's ultimately
what you're doing or live third-party
libraries you can import them
and then you can use them inside of your
application and so i'm saying
okay show me the loading screen if the
questions is null
but then show me the table and that
table has some logic in it which says
for each question in question so it's
looping through all of the questions
that i have
in this instance i've got two and it's
saying if
i equals current count on line 27 then
show that question
so i've got a really like a really ugly
way of basically saying
um look through all the questions and
only show the one
that it's currently set to and i've just
got a variable called
current count which is basically an
integer which is just going to be either
it's going to be zero or one in this
application and if a zero will show the
first question if it's one it will show
the second question
and if i had ten questions it obviously
would increment and only show that
particular
uh question and then at the bottom i
have these
buttons uh and it says on click that
button
then execute a c handler called previous
question
or one called next question so you'll
see
these are http html buttons
and they've got these two values in them
but they're just buttons and this is
sort of like a decoration that you can
put on blazer objects
to say invoke some c sharp and then the
actual handlers
well they just look like c sharp pandas
we've got a next question
and a previous question now
i said before the logic is really driven
by what the current count value is
because as i change the current count
value that
view is going to alter you can imagine
every time that you alter the
the application state it will update the
ui automatically so all i actually have
to do is alter the
current count variable to be the zero or
one and it will
effectively switching the questions the
view will look like the questions got
switched
so i just have a next question and a
previous question it's got some logic
basically to say
when i click next question and increment
the current count by one
but don't go any higher than i have
questions and then previous questions
do you exactly
take one off the current count but um
don't go lower than the one
so i now can have with these two buttons
i can navigate all of the questions in
my application
at the moment there's just two
so that's kind of the the view that i
have
so what this looks like is if i go to
questions now i've got my
question tabs or spaces and ants account
and if i click
next or previous it just basically
cycles through
what's cool about this is i'm not
updating the ui at all i'm just
updating my application state and the
ui's reflecting those changes
so the voting screen is really similar
but all i want to do is basically add
some buttons so they can vote
right so i've got a very similar sort of
setup but you'll see on line 37 here
um i've got a uh a button which says
vote
answer one or vote answer two and uh
it shows the um question information
about the question you'll see that when
i loop through the question object i can
access any of the properties of question
by just using this syntax at question
dot
answer one this is razer syntax if
you're not familiar with it if you've
never used asp.net pages before
um but i can basically create these uh
i put the title and then i've got in the
second column i've got answer one and
the second column i've got answer two as
buttons
and i do actually have on this version
of the application i built
i had like previous index buttons but i
don't actually use them in the real
application because i don't want users
to be able to switch questions
i want that to happen when the slide is
changed
by the presenter so now
um this is the vote screen it's exactly
the same but i just have effectively
buttons there
and uh what i need to do then is just
basically
um wire those buttons up so they can
vote
now this is the very first way that i
had to do it um
there's i want to use web sockets in my
application
now um to get at a websocket i need to
um the browser to effectively
the browse the underlying browser to
connect up to my websocket url
now at the time when i first started
building this there was no way
of doing that in c-sharp there is now so
i can set up a websocket
a websocket connection and in c-sharp
i can basically deal with the websocket
all in c
sharp but this is showing you a
mechanism that i had to
develop which is basically called
interoperability with javascript
so the version i'm going to show you now
contains a lot of javascript and
it kind of defeats the point of blazer
because i want to stay in c sharp
all of the bit that i just built the ui
all of that's in c sharp
but this bit is going to be in some
javascript and i'm not going to go too
deeply into the javascript because i'm
actually going to be able to remove all
of this
which is quite cool um but what i've
basically said is
when the application's initialized it's
going to invoke some javascript
which is actually hidden and it's
sitting in the in the
index html page and
basically connect over to this uh
websocket url
and when you when you do that
set up a reference.net reference back to
this application
and uh it's still got the same thing
when it's connected it's true
and then it says um when r is connected
then um
so basically it will get a response back
from the javascript and then r
should be either true or false and then
if it's true then it will be connected
so this websock is connected
then i load the sample questions in
again
on the html page i had this piece of
javascript that i'm interopering with
and it looks really similar to um
uh well
it's kind of painful because i've got a
connection method
a disconnect method and a vocal method
and
basically the way that i'm doing this is
i'm invoking this from c sharp then c
sharps creating the websocket then
invoking back the dotnet method
when a message comes in and you'll see
this dot net object reference invoke
method on vote
is then invoking a c-sharp method called
on-vote
and when someone votes it does it it
passes this information across
now this this this worked and i created
a new method in my application on my api
called vote
and basically now you can send this
particular your this
data over and say i want to vote
question id one answer one
and i was able to get into a scenario
where i've created a new serverless
function called vote on the server
it looks like this you can see it later
if you want
um the important thing is i had to do
this javascript interrupt
just to be able to use a websocket now
javascript interrupt is really
interesting in blazer because
there will be times when you're building
web applications that the
thing that you want to build just
doesn't exist in c sharp and you have to
invoke
or work with um with uh
javascript so you probably will find
yourself having to dip
into invoking javascript methods from c
sharp
in in your time when you're developing
laser applications
but it's cool that we won't have to do
this we don't have to do this anymore
so um let's just see
what that looks like now so i've got my
application it's connecting up to this
websocket
and when i click on answer one it sends
a message you can see on the
over here you can see that there is a a
message that's being sent over via a
websocket
um and so the person using the vote
screen can now
vote using that and so it's being sent
to the lambda function called vote
and then that votes being broadcast to
all the connected clients
the only client that's actually
listening to it though is the question
screen
which is receiving all of the different
votes and showing them on the screen as
they happen
so now if i if i basically show that so
i've got on the left hand side here
the uh i've got the left hand side i've
got the question
screen on the right hand side i've got
the vote screen and you'll see as i'm
voting
on the right-hand side it's sending a
message over to the question screen
and we'll be able to see like how people
are voting
now this is just tables and it looks a
little bit ugly but this is exactly the
same logic as i had in my vue.js
application that we used earlier
and you'll see as someone's as they're
tapping and so forth then it's um
updating both sides
so that's the real-time communication
stuff is kind of now working
but how do we kind of remove the
javascript
well i actually showed this talk in ndc
london
and i was when i came to like looking at
blazer i was a bit disappointed about
how quickly i had to jump into
javascript to do something which was
quite
relatively straightforward you see when
i do that fetch questions
um beforehand and we we go and make a
request
to get uh to get questions we're
actually
underlying using the network stack of
the browser to go and get those
questions
it's making a request and it's getting
rooted
uh now in in c sharp we're actually
using
the http client but what they've done in
the blaze
the blazer team they've kind of
intercepted http client and
wired it up to the browser so that you
can just use http client
and all of your but your network
requests are actually getting passed
through
to the browser so it's using the
networking stack of the browser
so that was really cool for http
requests but web sockets didn't work
like that we had to use this kind of
invoking javascript to create web
sockets
but now they've basically wired done a
similar
thing so they've basically intercepted
the
networking of websockets as well so you
can just create a websocket
as you would do ordinarily if you were
building a c-sharp
console application and you want to add
websockets to it
or a xamarin application and you want to
add web sockets to it well now you can
do that in a blazer application as well
and basically the networking aspect of
it is kind of wired back up to the
browser
so you're really using the browser to do
the network requests
but it looks and feels like you're using
c sharp um
and and that's doing it from the free
sharp c sharp so to show you that
i'm going to take you to obviously a
more finished application that i have
so this is the razer question
questions.razer view and you will see
that instead of invoking javascript what
i've got
is on the on initialize screen now i say
await websocket dot connect async and
obviously i do have
at the top here um i have system
system.net websockets i'm using that
uh library and i've got a few other
things as well that i'm using as well uh
newtonsoft.json
system.threading and various other
external things i'm also using
the http client which i'm having
injected
this websocket's not being injected i'm
just using the the instantiation i'm
creating an instantiation in the page
itself
so i'm not using dependency injection
and i'm saying
websocket.connect async and
i'm passing in a token because you can
dispose you can basically cancel
the the thing using the token and then
i'm
delegating it to receive loop and what
that means is that whenever this
websocket receives a message
it's going to call receive loop so
that's now my web this thing this
websocket is actually now a live
websocket in my csharp application
and i can i can reference that
do i use it at all in that page no i
don't
um i do on this one
i've got an echo that i don't and
one of my pages basically i can use it
in my view i can say websocket.state
and if it's open then i can show certain
things and if it's closed i can show
other things as well
so you can actually it's just a c-sharp
object then which you can use in your
application but it's intelligent enough
to know what it actually
underlying is the network communication
for a real web socket so we're going
back to the questions.razer
if i go to this receive loop question
where are we receive loop
let's show you on the vote screen
actually
so i set up the new websocket i call
receive loop as a delegate
basically when a message gets posted to
receive loop on the vote screen
what happens is when the presenter
changes the question the current
questions in view when they say
well i want it to be question one or
question two that sends a signal
up to the system the system then
broadcasts that message to all of the
connected clients
and that message ultimately comes back
into this receive loop
and what i do is i go okay i'm going to
take
the the websocket.receive async
information
and i'm going to receive it as text now
it's actually
json so i'm going to cast it as json as
a json object
i'm going to look for the message um
part of it
and if it's change question then i'm
basically going to change the question
which is currently displayed on the
screen
and change question all that does is
uh i'll just scroll to it uh change
question over here
basically changes voted to false um
changes current count to the current
question
and then cause this thing called state
has changed status change is an
interesting one you only you don't have
to call that all the time when you make
modifications to your objects
they will be reflected in the ui
automatically but because this is using
web sockets which might be coming back
on a different i think it's coming back
on a different thread or
it's not always on the ui occasionally
you might have to call status change to
just tell your application that
it needs to update the ui um i'm not
really
sure about the the built-in stuff about
that and why
you always have to call it but i found
that i had to call status change to
actually update the page
and so what this means now is let's go
and just
look at one of the browsers if i go over
to the laser front end
and
i'll take that one over there and just
pop that
on that side
there we go and then if i just take one
over here
oh god why is it doing that
there we go sorry about this uh
so i've got uh let's put the vote
question on one side
and the questions on one and so
hopefully
he's connected okay
yes that is working as i change the
screen on questions you can see anyone
which is connected to the vote screen
the the title is changing as i'm
changing
the question so i went to tabs and
spaces but everyone connected is getting
the new question
if you see and then i can answer and so
forth and all of that stuff happens
over um over signal r
so my actual application i've just got a
couple of minutes to talk about this
it's basically broken into a uh
a couple of sort of folders i have um
my blazer front end which is my my front
end application which does the websocket
communications and allows the voting
and then i have a number of projects for
each of my lambda functions so i have an
onconnect
function an on disconnect function a
send message function
and a slide function and the way that i
actually deploy
this application if i want to deploy it
is there's a folder
a file sorry inside um
the back end if i want to deploy the
lambda functions
and here is uh
something called a serverless
application model
you don't need to worry about what it is
in rider and in visual studio
i can do this thing where i just
basically right click on one of these
templates and say deploy serverless
application
and then the application i can deploy to
um
to aws so i just say i want to update
this and deploy it
click on deploy and what it'll do is
it'll build my application
and it will then deploy it out to aws
lambda
and um then i'm able to sort of use this
and publish it uh
to live the advantage i'd say over
using this over um the the setup that i
had before
is that this only ever costs me money
if um someone invit like actually goes
to my website and uses it
um otherwise i don't pay for anything
the the way that the costing works with
lambda is that you only pay pay
per per request that's being um being
served
you don't pay for the infrastructure
which it runs on
so that's kind of that's kind of it if
you want the code it's on my github i'm
at the biebs on github
i'm at the beams on twitter as well and
uh
i'll be developing this application and
hopefully get to the same point that
they look identical
and they operate identically and if you
want to help me then
by all means you can jump on that github
and start working out with me as well
thank you very much indeed